is that the black queen points towards
that little guy over around black's king
and i think he's going for this now so
this is uh is this turning around in
magnus's favor possibly yeah and look at
the computer evaluation there it did say
that this last move by black bringing
the knight to this square was actually
the only way to maintain the balance but
it also does give black the advantage
and now if we see the computer
suggestions after this night check no
matter what white does black has an
advantage i mean the most obvious move
is also the best move here according to
stockfish according to the computer
that's taking this night that will
happen i'm pretty sure and now black
most likely is going to jump in with his
queen and capture a pawn i mean even
that is not forced i mean there are
options here you could even just take
this pawn with your own pawn and uh hit
the white queen for example if the white
queen recaptures you can actually save
both your queen and the rook at the same
time by lifting your queen up and
offering a trade
so
suddenly level neroni lost control maybe
just trying to be a bit too clever by
bringing his knight in earlier he's
probably going to lose now after i say
that but let's see
more pawns getting exchanged this this
is only helping the defender yeah and
now if black's king goes and takes the
white pawn next to it then white's
knight will actually go to the edge of
the board with a check and that's a
double attack it will go back and
capture black's pawn on the c6 square so
yeah everything we're about to see that
happen everything getting traded this
one is just a dead draw now all right
then enough material left to check me
hopefully we're going to make it to the
ending of ding against jesse panko yep
it is a draw in this one